les anti pacs accuse big format de nous
empoisonner mais c'est quoi big pharma
en fait
ça lui rudy bonjour l'ena big pharma
c'est le nom de la théorie complotiste
qui dit que les labos pharmaceutiques
s'entendent à l'échelle mondiale pour
faire des bénéfices financiers sur notre
dos au mépris du bien commun les vaccins
contre le coc vite c'est quand même une
très bonne affaire pour eux non oui
c'est indéniable mais c'est pas un peu
immoral
certains laboratoires qui commercialise
des vaccins contrôle qu'ovide ont décidé
de vendre leurs vaccins prix coûtant
tout cas par l'aîné 2021 d'autres ceux
qui ont développé la fameuse technologie
arn messagers font beaucoup plus de
bénéfice mais explique qu'ils ont pris
un risque industriel taser par exemple
investi deux milliards de dollars dans
son magasin si ça n'avait pas marché les
pertes auraient été pour mais pourquoi
on n'a pas plutôt mis en avant des
traitements qui coûte moins cher comme
l'hydro xi chloroquine l'ivermectine par
exemple parce que les deux molécules
dont tu parles n'ont pas fait la preuve
scientifiquement de leur efficacité
s'agissant de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
qui était mise en avant par le
professeur out aujourd'hui le consensus
scientifique sur le sujet est très clair
ça ne marche pas oui mais on peut quand
même se demandaient si les labos
pharmaceutiques n'ont pas justement fait
passer à ses traitements pour une
efficace non et il s'y serait pris
comment il aurait pu convaincre les
scientifiques innovant la solution du
vaccin de toute façon des scientifiques
qui ont des liens d'intérêt avec les
labos ça doit exister non ça veut dire
que les laboratoires pharmaceutiques
auraient achetés et donc corrompu tous
les scientifiques du monde pour faire
croire qu'il n'y avait pas de traitement
contre le co lead c'est quand même une
cause manière de voir les choses et
c'est d'autant plus faux que faiseur
vient de sortir un traitement contre les
copies jusqu au début de la pandémie on
a entendu dire que le conte vite c'était
un plan de big pharma pour décimer la
population mondiale dans ce cas pourquoi
les labos pharmaceutiques ont mis au
point des vaccins qui dans les faits
pour sauver des millions de vies ça
c'est toi qui dit on dit aussi que les
vaccins sont une manière de nous
empoisonner
désolé mais ça tient pas la route si le
vaccin est un poison s'en serait rendu
compte parce que les milliards de
personnes ont été vaccinées
qu'elle se porte bien à moins d'estimer
que tous les journalistes ont aussi dans
le coup et suspecté les scientifiques de
collusion avec un grand projet criminel
fantasmatique ça c'est vivre dans un
monde parallèle d'autant que les labos
ont besoin de plus de clients a priori
pas de les tuer et si un jour on
découvre que les vaccins nous rendent
malades sur le long terme depuis que les
vaccins existent il ya des gens qui sont
imax en or ce qu'on peut dire avec
certitude à la clé recul historique
c'est que 1 la vaccination sauvent des
vies depuis des dizaines d'années et
deux si on s'était fié aux anti vaccins
on aura encore aujourd'hui des épines
habib aux enjeux de varicelle de rubéole
qui tuerait chaque année des milliers
d'enfants
[Musique]